there still are people that believe that  you killed your sister  evidence or the lack thereof dr. Phil  leaves no stone unturned and his final  sit down with JonBenet Ramsey's brother  Burke the now twenty nine-year-old  addresses those who doubt his innocence  in his sister's death all of this  cover-up was all done to protect you  because they didn't want to lose two  children that's their theory I don't  have to say that because I know that's  not what happened there's been a few  people that said that's not even  physically possible for a nine-year-old  to do that Burke says he still talks to  his late sister when you talk to her  what would you say oh it's like if  there's some important thing I was doing  there hey thanks for looking out for me  Burke is not it has never been a suspect  in this case in our final episode what  you're going to hear is Burke has a very  specific theory about who killed his  sister the final part of dr. Phil's  sit-down with Burke airs Monday